and now to breaking news overnight from
the Middle East Palestinian militants
fought with the Israeli soldiers in the
West Bank City of Janine after Israel's
biggest military assault in the area in
decades at least eight Palestinians are
dead and dozens are injured Israel calls
it an anti-terror operation raymie and
asensio has more from London Remy good
morning
good morning Christina yeah Israel's
Army first struck the Northern West Bank
City of Janine with multiple drones and
then entered with hundreds if not close
to 2 000 troops they targeted a building
they said served as a command center for
Palestinian militants and said the raid
was a counter-terrorism effort in a city
that they now call a hornet's nest for
terrorists now this all started around
1am and set off gun battles that went on
after Sunrise Israel's Army also
bulldozed roads apparently to make sure
there were no hidden roadside bombs in
them the number of dead is expected to
rise though that is from the Palestinian
Authority's Health Ministry separately
another Palestinian was killed by
Israeli troops while protesting the
Janine right there now the Palestinian
Authority says Israel has committed a
new war crime Israel's air defense
systems are on alert right now for
possible retaliation Ed
Remy thank you